Breaking into the Chinese
market is critical to the
long-term success of any international company.
Consumer spending in China
is set to double by 2030,
to nearly $13 trillion - the same
amount Americans currently spend.
Yet many foreign firms have a hard time
navigating a market as complex as China.
When Amazon entered China in 2004 by
acquiring the Chinese shopping site
Joyo.com for about $75 million, it believed it
could replicate its stunning success in America.
Unfortunately for Jeff Bezos, his foray
into East Asia didn’t go as planned.
Amazon shut down its Chinese domestic
e-commerce marketplace in 2019.
Yet since Elon Musk set up a
Tesla Gigafactory in Shanghai,
demand for his electric cars has been booming.
China is responsible for producing
half of Tesla’s cars worldwide in 2021.
China rocks in my opinion. The energy in China is
great. People there – there’s like
a lot of smart, hard-working people.
Selling electric cars and selling everyday
goods are obviously two different industries.
Yet one can argue you CAN make
a comparison. Both are American
companies that tried to make inroads in
China but adopted very different strategies.
Despite entering China early, Amazon
struggled to compete against Tmall.com,
owned by Alibaba Group, which has since grown to
become the country’s leading e-commerce platform.
Amazon’s market share fell from 15 percent
in 2011….to less than 1 percent by 2018.
Nor could Amazon China compete with
the other dominant player, JD.com.
Part of the problem was that
Amazon failed to innovate in China.
When Alibaba introduced its own payment platform,
Alipay, in which people could pay digitally
for products they ordered on Tmall, Amazon was
still accepting cash from buyers upon delivery.
Amazon also failed to understand
what appealed to Chinese shoppers.
Alibaba’s annual shopping extravaganza
Singles Day was a huge hit. Amazon didn’t
have a counter as its annual discounted
event Prime Day didn’t exist yet.
The websites of Tmall and JD were
also very colorful and festive.
Amazon’s website looked rather bland -
mirroring its other home pages around
the world. Americans prefer a minimalist
design, which is not the case in China.
It didn’t help that Amazon China relied
on support from company headquarters in
Seattle and was slow to respond to market signals.
The company also turned off Chinese sellers.
Sellers were used to paying 2% to 5%
of their sales to Alibaba in addition
to paying for ads to make their
listings more prominent. However,
Amazon executives were not a fan of
the advertising model and instead,
charged Chinese sellers more, 10% to 15% of
sales. So naturally, they flocked to Alibaba.
Perhaps the biggest mistake Jeff Bezos
made in China…was that he failed to
understand the importance of forging
good relations with the government.
As Brad Stone writes in his book about
Amazon’s growth called Amazon Unbound,
“Amazon.cn executives from that time said
that Bezos was totally uninterested in
understanding the inner machinations of
the Chinese government, cultivating ties
with Chinese leaders, or using his budding
fame to help Amazon’s cause in the country…”
Elon Musk didn’t make the same mistake when he
opened Tesla’s first factory in China in 2019.
Musk has consistently made an
effort to woo Chinese officials.
Taking China’s ambassador to the U.S. for a
drive in a Model S Plaid - which the ambassador
described as a “smooth ride”. It’s unclear if they
tried plaid mode - the fastest acceleration mode.
On his Weibo account, Musk frequently praises
China’s space program and economic
growth over the past three decades.
The Chinese government has
been very supportive of Tesla.
In 2019, Tesla became the first foreign
automaker to open an independent factory
in China. Normally, foreign carmakers
must team up with a Chinese partner.
There apparently was no excessive red tape as
Tesla built its Shanghai Gigafactory in record
time: going from permits to a finished plant
in just 168 working days or about six months!
Tesla was one of 600 businesses that the
Chinese government deemed important enough
to open first amid the lockdown
in Shanghai in the spring of 2022.
Authorities arranged buses to transport
thousands of Tesla workers and helped
carry out the required disinfection
to curb the spread of COVID-19.
Musk has heaped praise on Chinese workers, like
in this interview with the Financial Times.
There’s just a lot of super talented,
hardworking people in China that are who
strongly believe in manufacturing. They
won’t just be burning the midnight oil,
they’ll be burning the 3 a.m. oil. They
won’t even leave the factory type of thing,
whereas in America, people are
trying to avoid going to work at all.
While Amazon China failed to
get close to Chinese consumers,
the minimalist website being one example, Musk
has really tried to embrace Chinese culture.
When he posted an ancient Chinese poem
about the importance of getting along,
on his social media accounts, it went
viral, as people discussed what he meant.
While Amazon China relied on Seattle for support,
Tesla China is not simply a branch of Tesla.
It’s set up to do original
research and development work.
Tesla opened a research center and a separate data
center in Shanghai in 2021. Both
are located near the Gigafactory.
Musk’s push for EV development
conveniently aligns with Chinese
president Xi Jinping’s pledge to make
China the leader in electric innovation.
Beijing aims to have 40 percent of
vehicles sold in China be electric by 2030.
And Elon Musk is the one
person who can get them there.
It’s no wonder Beijing has been showering
Tesla with goodies such as cheap land,
low-interest loans, and tax incentives -
exempting Tesla cars from a 10% purchase tax.
Within three years of opening, Giga
Shanghai is now on track to produce 900,000
cars a year if recent monthly
deliveries are any indication.
And it’s building another assembly
line near its existing plant,
which could add another half a
million Model 3s and Model Ys a year.
According to Tesla, this will turn Shanghai
into "the world's largest vehicle export hub".
Musk has remained popular in China
despite deteriorating relations with
the U.S. I’ve made a series of videos
recently on how Washington is trying to
keep the world’s most critical chip
technology out of Beijing’s hands.
There’s also the issue of large-scale
human rights abuses in the country.
So, it’s a delicate balance for Musk to
straddle the geopolitical fault lines.
But Elon Musk needs China.
Chinese sales helped propel
Tesla to its first full year
of profitability in 2020 - 18 years in the making.
And China needs Elon Musk.
Chinese leaders have reportedly grown frustrated
with the performance of domestic electric vehicle
companies, and believe Tesla can lead
the transition to an electric future.
Although, Chinese companies
are starting to catch up.
In the third quarter of 2022, BYD sold 537,164
new energy vehicles compared
to Tesla’s 343,830 vehicles.
However, only about half of BYD’s
car sold were fully electric as
new energy vehicles also include plug-in
hybrids and hydrogen fuel-cell vehicles.
So Tesla is still ahead in
all-electric vehicle sales.
For now, Tesla is enjoying a fate that is very
different from Amazon’s in the
world’s most populous country.
Tesla’s success lies in its ability to innovate
quickly. As Musk has said time and time again,
what matters is the pace of innovation.
Well, another company is
innovating an everyday product.
I used to carry around quite a bulky wallet but
wanted something that was sleek and slimmer.
So it was a no-brainer for me
to pick up an Ekster wallet.
I started using an Ekster wallet before they
approached me about sponsoring some of my videos.
I especially like Ekster’s AirTag
wallet - there’s a convenient spot
for my Apple air tag so I know
where my wallet is at all times.
No matter what model of wallet you get - can
access all your cards with a click of a button.
I also really like this carbon fiber wallet Ekster
sent me which I think just looks great. They’ve
also got a solar-powered tracking
device you can get along with it.
Ekster has a huge selection of wallets on
their website - including s a vegan leather
smart wallet made with recycled material
sourced from scrapped car windshields.
If you’d like to try out an Ekster wallet for
yourself or gift one to family and friends, you
can get 20% off if you use my custom
link: https://shop.ekster.com/newsthink.
shop.ekster.com/newsthink. The link is
in my description and pinned comment.
Thanks for watching. For Newsthink, I’m Cindy Pom.